welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of Andor
episode 8 narkina 5. and narkina 5
really should be the name of the
five-man boy band after they struck that
pose
[Music]
I'm sorry let's break down all the
visual details of Star Wars Easter eggs
that you might have missed this episode
composer Nicholas Patel updates some
music over the opening title so that now
it sounds like a hammer on metal
[Music]
echoing the sounds of Cassian and his
labor crew assembling this Imperial
Machinery in prison Cassian has moved
off of niyamos as a tan armored short
Trooper barks Roman
yeah this stripper is not credited as a
different actor so it's probably once
again Mall voice actor Sam Wentworth
doing an uncredited Cameo like he did as
a short Trooper last episode the
drippers sort the prisoners into
transports based on how able-bodied they
are the guy brought up Cassian tuck
hybacks is from galdi and is sent to
belsavis which is a planet from Star
Wars Legends in 1995 Children of the
Jedi novel in the Old Republic stories
it's a frozen planet used as a hiding
place of young Jedi who escaped The
Purge like roganda is Marin who was also
made Canon as one of the Jedi names on
the wall in Obi-Wan Kenobi this idea of
immediately sorting prisoners into labor
camps and rushing them off is one of
many dark parallels in this episode to
Nazi concentration camps George Lucas
has depicted the Empire space Nazi since
the beginning I mean have you seen the
wings on dangerous pants this episode
continues the metaphor in the way the
prisoners are just so efficiently sorted
and shipped off to different labor camps
to focus on the taking off of the shoes
reminding us of the heartbreaking last
Witnesses exhibit at the U.S Holocaust
Memorial Museum and the way these
prisoners are lined up for showers this
whole place is just a well-oiled machine
of Cruelty we cut to Cyril Carn in the
Bureau of Standards the first shot is
literally what he sees from his cubicle
when he looks up I think he might be
playing a game on his terminal Batman is
playing Galaga
there aren't really any numbers or text
on his screen just flashing shapes this
kind of looks like a 70s game console
screen this whole episode frames all of
these prisoners toilings is a kind of
game the prisoners of narquina 5
literally competing against each other
you play against all the other tables in
this room I play against all the other
rooms please call it what you will
competing for petty food based Rewards
or to avoid pain Cyril Khan playing his
games and if you think about all these
characters are in a kind of squid game
but I guess in Monmouth in this case
it's a Squig game no I'm not post serial
supervisors follow a mouse droid to his
cubicle I'm assuming this is the same
mouse story that nearly tripped him when
he walked to his desk last episode while
cassian's cuffs are magnetically sealed
in place we cut to Cyril's knee bouncing
nervously as he waits to be interrogated
for filing false inquiries looking for
Cassian Cyril corrects Dedra from five
to six inquiries showing he's not
ashamed of his actions one would think
you'd want to leave ferricks as far
behind as possible one could be wrong
yeah another parallel between Karen and
Andor they both keep returning to
ferricks despite how stupid it is for
them to go go back to it narkina 5 has
floating prison facilities if you count
there are seven of them seven is magic
number seven bases shaped as seven-sided
heptagons seven levels seven rooms seven
tables seven men per table and later we
find out seven seconds to return to your
cell when the lights start flashing May
remind you of the Saint Ives riddle as I
was going to say knives I met a man with
seven wives each wife had seven sacks
each sack had seven cats each cat had
seven kids kids cats sex and wives how
many were going to say knives and if you
watch Die Hard with vengeance you know
that the answer is of course one only
you are going to say knives similarly
this facility buries you in this number
game so that you lose sight of yourself
now seven is a prime number and has
various different meanings to different
mythologies and fictions seven deadly
sins the lucky number seven God created
the world in seven days seven gods in
the faith of the seven in Game of
Thrones seven horcruxes for Harry Potter
Dante's seventh circle of hell houses
the violent but here I think seven is
less about symbolism than it is just
about harmonic balance since all groups
are kept in competition with each other
seven groups is a large enough number to
keep each group motivated to avoid being
last but to also feel Pride if they top
the others notice how Aquino only cares
about being in the top three of his
level seven is also an odd number to
prevent mutinous coalitions from forming
and to encourage fluidity among the
factions with seven descent is overalled
quickly and it's just easier to conform
and with the prisoners keeping each
other honest and getting each other
motivated it all plays out like a
Stamford Prison Experiment now as the
transport arrives you see how each base
is surrounded by whirlpools at the point
these might come from engines that keep
the bases suspended which doesn't make a
lot of sense really my darkest theory
for what they are making in these rooms
are just machine parts and turbines just
to perpetuate the prison itself with no
other Imperial purpose which in some
ways would be even more messed up than
if they're building parts of the Death
Star Miro produces the Imperial starpath
unit that she recovered from barracks
and she pauses for Wolf you'll Lauren to
catch up my full report highlights the
prevalence of this problem galaxy-wide
I'm listening oh whoa you Lauren always
Charming us since your first Cameo on
the Death Star in the New Hope and he's
so good at multitasking I really hope
he's reading reports from his good buddy
Grant Admiral thrawn because if you
watch Rebels you know those two are
friends Miro reveals they have code
named Lutheran axis
acts the kind of fulcrum upon which the
current phase of
the word axis also pretty ironic when
you remember that the Axis powers
included the Nazis in World War II and
we learned the purpose of the prisoner's
bare feet in the guards insulated boots
let's go the warden reveals that the
floors are made of tungstoid steel this
is a substance from the 2009 novel fate
of the Jedi Abyss kudos to Diego Luna
and these other actors for their
perfectly synced contortions it looks
incredibly painful especially for
Cassian whose feet and hand touched the
floor even more points of contact even
more pain and notice how the warden
Smiles just a bit enjoying the sadism of
this before catching himself to release
them Karen tells mirror that he didn't
get a good look at Lutheran remember
back in episode three Cassian held him
at gunpoint and Karn was in a variable
to turn around to see luton's face he
only saw him as a blur when he passed on
the Speeder bike and as Mira leaves
Karin still Smiles a bit to himself
comforted that he made an impression on
her and that someone is finally
investigating the ferric's incident as
Cassian is brought into his work room he
clocks where the guards hang their boots
and each boot is stamped with an
imperial Crest he also notices how truly
inefficient and easily thrown off
schedule these guards are showing that
it's really the design of the facility
not the Personnel that makes it so
secure I think this will all be useful
next episode when they escape the
prisoners all wear white creamsicle
uniforms in a mostly white facility
recalling the production design of
George Lucas is dystopian sci-fi thx1138
we meet the floor manager Kino Loy
played by Andy Circus who's of course
played supreme leader snoke in the
sequels and he says losing hope your
mind
so already I just get this guy way more
than anything we learned about snow
Cassian meets his table gembach zal taga
Olaf ham and melshi and malshe should
look familiar Duncan Powell played
runescott melshi in Rogue one he was a
rebel commander in cassian's unit who
helped Cassie and break jyn urso out of
the women's prison on wobani and leads a
rebel faction in the bunker on Scarab
Olaf is played by Christopher Fairbank
who played the thug in the 1989 Batman
who set up this iconic moment what are
you you
I'm Batman ooloff struggles to keep up
during the sudden Sprint segment
reminding us of the heart pounding speed
test that Eamon Gutt puts the worker
under to make that hinge in Schindler's
List now all the workers are totally in
the dark with theories about what's
really going on they notice the guards
outside are laughing they speculate that
Kino is actually the one in charge I
guess putting them all through this like
he's an Undercover Boss I feel like
there's also a meta joke here like they
recognize Andy circus's snow can have
their own fan theories about snoke being
everything now it is not clear what
they're building yet it does have six
arms that are bent inward obviously this
would be something the Empire would need
a lot of if it's being mass produced
like this so if it's not turbines to
keep the facility afloat I did speculate
they could be parts of TIE fighter
cockpits like this facility might be
part of an imperial contract with assign
our Fleet systems or or they could be
the hexagonal nodes to build the
framework of the curved Death Star there
are only four episodes left of the
season of Andor it's so good I don't
want it to end and thanks to Star Wars
card Trader I can get all my favorite
Andor moments on my phone so the
Rebellion is always in my pocket look
here's Sim to contemplating the
consequences of the aldani heist Star
Wars card Trader by tops lets you open
Digital packs to collect your favorite
Star Wars characters weapons and moments
it's not just and or characters get
yourself a Leia a Goku or a cat Bane too
once you up in the packs you can connect
and trade cards and fans across the
Galaxy to complete sets get free cards
and credits daily to grow your
collection there's so much to this app
you can create missions to unlock unique
content or craft your cards into rarer
ones at the workbench they're always
releasing new cards set so the fun of
collecting never has to end join me now
on Star Wars card Trader by tops by
downloading the app from the link in
this video's description find me on
there under the username new rockstars
backs to propose a trade Monmouth and
her husband parent drink a chandrillan
drink by dropping squigs that
disintegrate and Fizz toasting with the
term sagrona and sagranatima man is
trying to secure votes against the
emperor's latest overreach with por-d
and remembers Perrin when he's 15 years
old
that's not the academy five round we
later learned that Mon and Perrin were
actually part of an arranged marriage as
teenagers per achangerland custom Perrin
and take homea trade barbs good luck
feeding the Galaxy I'm off to feed
myself charity begins at home the look
parent gets Tay after that Juan mata's
daughter later interrupts their scheming
you here are the time now
learning to love Corazon you're drinking
squigs no I've lost my taste for it it's
disgusting but that's the point so yeah
it sounds like chandrillans drink these
squigs as a snobby delicacy and later
definitely seems to be suspicious of
take Homer she might be the one who ends
up reporting him and blowing her
mother's money moving operation on the
bridge Thai guy uses hand signals with
an inmate across the way so a prison
break may already be in the early
development even without casting and
planning it mod chats with Senators Dao
Florida tinar and Gibbon would give in
defending the emperor is just doing his
job to protect everyone someone in this
group says what do you mean ah says what
he means hey luckily says what he means
what obviously commonly said about
supposedly populist politicians in the
real world who actually don't really say
anything and actually don't really mean
anything it's all hot air hey no editor
please don't show an image for that they
all flipped out when I reference Mark's
a few episodes back gem box shows Cassie
and his cell where they get food from a
tube it's a lot like an umbilical cord
it's super and finalizing isn't it when
it gets taste with their food
top table with flavor cassian's number
is 2180 his sentence was six years which
in Earth years would be 21.90 so if we
assume 10 days on yamos it does line up
now yes it does not really make sense
for Star Wars years and days to line up
with the orbital cycles of Earth around
our sun but you know it just does so get
over it Jim box says everyone's number
was doubled last month as a result of
the por-d and taga is shocked to learn
no one on the outside knows or cares
about this they speculate that a
Garrison was slaughtered by rebels even
though it was just a robbery that's some
Imperial propaganda at play there and
Olaf cell it looks like there's only 74
days left that tracks with him being one
of the older inmates but it also implies
that hey he has been here for several
years and still never moved up the
ladder to where Kino is despite Kino
having more days left on his sentence
and B last month his number was half of
that because it was doubled remember so
he was so close to release last month
and in this episode when we shipped
ahead 30 days to the point where Olaf
probably should have been released this
is when he starts to stumble it's just
so heartbreaking something's probably
gonna happen to this guy he probably
would have been free if not for the poor
descendancy and increases that cash
cause or not cause like it wasn't his
decision to do it but obviously his
choice has led to it and he's probably
gonna feel a lot of guilt for it or he
should feel a lot of guilt for it but
not that much guilt you know it's the
Empire's fault Leda eats a snack which
looks a lot like one of those teal
macaroons you know not macaroons and
macarons that grogu snacked on in the
Mandalorian cassians never transitioned
from 2180 to 2150 and we see 30 shifts
later they don't measure their time in
days they measure it in shifts because
they don't see the outdoors they don't
know if it's day or night or what
Cassian is eating off of a plate
suggesting that his table won a recent
ship because otherwise wouldn't all
their food come in the tubes right all
the prisoners stand naked to get
sanitized echoing the prison shower
montage and Shawshank Redemption and we
nearly see our first Star Wars ass crack
from Andy's circus but the booty never
makes it into frame they retrieve clean
clothes from cubby holes like the farex
workers glove wall in episode one and
even these person guards boot rack it
seems like everyone in this Imperial
machine is kept on a routine like
children in school Olaf jams the pin and
Kino comes over in a solid Gordon Ramsay
and Hell's Kitchen impression bye
you're just taking a breather come on
guys you got a chance of winning the
ship today
I'm ashamed to waste it
yeah Kino's smile is totally
performative it's a tool that he uses to
reassure and motivate like Lutheran's
final smile everybody's violin is used
as weapon or a mass on ferex Brasso
walks past an imperial Speeder Bike the
kind we saw in corellia and solo a Star
Wars story he and Bix check in on Marva
who fell trying to open a Floodgate on
Rick's road to see if a tunnel was open
under the hotel so that Rebels could
catch the Imperials by surprise Val and
sento wait for Andor to show up Santa
wants to stand up for a while to stay
and watch but not with Vel as that would
draw too much attention who would you
say you are
maybe I'm a rich girl running away from
her family
it's cold
even for you now I have been thinking
that Bell might be Lutheran's daughter
because they do look pretty similar but
if she would be running away from her
family in that case she'd be working for
her father's business so I don't know
about that but it seems like she's gonna
be related to someone important maybe
take Homa or maybe one of those other
Senators Bix calls Luth and shop now
Lutheran has a few new items you move
that white Jedi Temple guard mask onto
the central pedestal beside a headpiece
that looks like padme's Naboo Crest
headdress from Attack of the Clones
which you can get a Galaxy's Edge
there's also some chest armor that looks
a lot like Mandalorian best guard sadly
apparently no one wants to buy The
gungan Shield or that Starkiller armor
Clea tells luthin that he is slipping
and he agrees to shut down the pharynx
frequency unfortunately for Bix on her
end the lights stayed lit so she has no
way of knowing if the other side is even
listening anymore as that overhead shot
of her suggests she is literally siled
another great shop composition showing
some cross dissolving from Belle on the
ferric shuttle to Santa spying on the
Andor home like Anakin and padme's
longing glances across the city from
their windows in Revenge of the set a
prisoner named bemos takes his life by
stepping on the red floor we actually
saw him earlier in the shower and he has
some scarring on the side of his face
this might not be the first time he's
tried to do this the others say that he
railed it which might be their slang in
the way people in underground metros
will jump in front of trains or touch
the electrified third rail Lutheran
takes his fundor Hall craft to sigra
Milo to meet up with sagarrera's
partisan group a few familiar faces from
Rogue one return benthic two tubes and
then down below if you look closely
that's more off the Gregorian they also
have a few early model x-wings this
would be after the income Corporation
has transitioned away from the z95
models you'll notice these x-wings have
the Astromech Port Forest Whitaker
returns to sagarrera who does not yet
need a breathing mask as he doesn't
broke one he is younger and healthier
here though still he has the scar across
his face that he has in the rebels era
Lutheran once saw to meet with a rebel
named Anto Krieger to give him air
support as he attacks an imperial power
station on spellhouse but saw is
reluctant to merge their efforts
a separatist my base a new Republican
the Gorman front the partisan Alliance
sectorists human cultists Galaxy
partitionists they're lost separatists
refers to clone wars era Confederacy of
independent systems Gorman Fred those
are the Freedom Fighters according to
Gormans whom Monmouth has been talking a
lot about all these groups are just
various anti-empire political alliances
all of which have failed Bix gets
arrested and Dedra orders pot to be left
in the room so that Bix can seize
tortured body and the desert can pretend
that this was a mistake she's just a
very skilled interrogator I'm really
worried about Bix we end on cassian's
team toiling away as more and more of
these parts get assembled assuming these
are pieces of the Death Star it's pretty
sad to think that these prisoners are
once again the instruments of their own
destruction but one question I'm left
with assuming Cassian left his credits
above the shower back on the Amos did he
also leave nimix Manifesto there too we
need to protect that document at all
costs I mean I guess you could argue a
political text in any reader's hand
remains valuable as long as a person
doesn't want to burn the book but damn I
am hoping that Cassian stashed it back
on ferrics for Marva to bring to book
club with the daughters Barracks follow
me on Tick Tock Instagram and Twitter at
eavos following rockstars And subscribe
to new rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]